um did you i saw the many saints of
newark have you seen that movie yet i
haven't seen it yet this is weird
and i i i i don't want to talk about
this because i don't want people to get
the wrong idea i know that a lot of
people are they have a you know
obviously i love joey diaz who's in the
movie
and i love a lot of um
the people that are that are in the
movie right i mean the sopranos is an
epic show i don't
it's weird the direction they took
to me i think it's odd
um
it's strange to me
to
do a prequel
where a huge element of the character
that was not at all in the
show is brought out
that's weird to me
the prequel
uh to the many states of newark is about
how tony soprano like got into the mafia
and
the entire movie
i don't know if you know this
but is literally and this is a little
[ __ ]
why he was smiling
the entire movie
is tony
getting into the mafia
because he's gay
and he's trying to hide his sexuality
from
other people and he feels the most
effective way to do that
and
there are sex scenes
where tony
soprano is having sex with men in this
movie
as the receptive partner he's taking it
in the movie and
people were shocked at this the whole
crux of the movie
is that tony's in an interrelational uh
interracial relationship in newark with
a man
this is odd
to me because in the sopranos there was
never
a thought
that ah listen i'm a gay guy i think gay
cinema is great but there was never a
thought that tony was gay
so to me to make
his character gay
and give him this the story arc of
having a love interest
is very very strange and even if you did
all of that
the
visceral nature of a lot of these sex
scenes
i mean it's
really aggressive
it's aggressive
but this is what hollywood has decided
to do
and i'm i'm emailing you right there's a
scene
because you know that i was asked to
audition for this oh you did i was asked
to audition for this so i got the script
and
there is a scene that me and you are
going to read
from the many saints of newark okay and
i again i worry
i worry that
you know again i don't want to offend
anyone that really enjoyed the picture
but i think
that it's worth stating how different
this is
than most of what
we've come to expect
from the david chase
and the sopranos do you have it did you
get it i'm
there it goes
okay so
we're this is a scene
from the many saints of newark and again
i'm
so here don't read it read it as you do
it that's what a real actor does okay
okay who am i
you're african-american man
now i want you to start
i want you to start
describe the scene up top
okay you want me to be the narrator yes
okay
tony a young sexually confused man
explores gender and sexuality with older
men in the mafia this is
weird
right
i mean let's be honest is this
is this not
is this not weird
this is not
what i thought the movie was going to be
about and listen i don't do a good tony
soprano impression that's not what i'm
trying to do here
what i'm trying to do is act and breathe
life into the scene okay so let's start
okay tony is sitting on a
is sitting on a bench by the basketball
court he notices a young
african-american man playing basketball
shirtless tony is shy at first but
brings to speak to him
well that i don't know why that was
written like that
hey what are you doing
okay so i'm african-american right
you're the man
this is tony's at a basketball court
he's watching an african-american man
play basketball shirtless and tony is
sitting there and i think in the movie
he's eating an ice cream cone
seductively
but
that was added
later
again this is the many saints of newark
okay this is true all right i i'm only
laughing because
i'm
stunned that they went in this direction
okay tony you shied first but speaks to
him hey what are you doing i'm playing
ball what are you doing watching you
watching you like what you say hey what
you're doing right now with the the
black hands and stuff
it's not necessary okay you know what i
mean do you know what you just did
you're like i'm playing ball black
people don't talk like that
do you see what you did when you're
going into the 70s i'm trying to think
of how they'd play it yeah it's like
it's groovy i think you're jus just
really just respect the work okay
okay i don't think we need to start
doing a dance okay okay
hey what are you doing i'm playing ball
what are you doing watching you like
what you see
okay it's
i'm playing ball what are you doing
watching you like what you see watching
you like what you see yeah
maybe i do
maybe i do
let me ask you something
do yous have bigger dicks than us
you know like that's what people say
only one way to find out
you guys must have real brazil's over
there where you come from i'm italian
i'm in the mafia or at least i will be
but i can't tell anyone that i'm you
know into men
i know what that's like you do
my pastor says that gay people go to
hell he calls them three dollar bills
your church that's what they do is
screaming and everything hey you think
anyone is there right now
maybe we could go over there
you want to see my church i want to see
you
tony pulls the man close to him and they
begin making out tony is grabbing his
crotch the man seems uncomfortable with
all the people around
not here we can have sex in my church
so
this is
crazy to me then they go have sex in a
church
where tony is getting it in the ass
and it's crazy so is there like a gospel
choir and everything but they're in the
back no it's an empty church okay and
he's just like pounding tony
and then tony says i don't know if i
want you just this is a quote for the
movie tony goes i don't know if i want
you to explode in me but i i also want
to taste you
and then the guy goes
well have you heard of felchick and tony
goes no what's that and the guy goes
that's where i would come inside of you
and then suck it out with a straw or
something and then spit it back in your
mouth all i'm saying is this is very
surprising to me
that's what i'm saying
again
go see the film make your own decisions
it's very surprising that they went in
this direction personally
you know
i mean the whole thing
when we meet carmella
like it's crazy because he's like having
sex with guys is weird
anyway
that's just putting it that's just my
two cents